so today starting to do person Thomas
Aquinas and I've got this famous
painting in I learn as the image for
your first section on him and he's
standing there holding two things in his
hands he's holding on a model church in
one hand regular left and that he's got
a book in the other and that book is
actually Aristotle so what we have with
Thomas Aquinas is somebody who is
continuing the theories of someone to be
the study know which would be thinner
stuff so you're going to see some of the
same issues come up again he is a
commentator he's an interpreter of air
so but like everybody who's interpreting
he's placing Aristotle in his own time
just like when we just talked about this
application assignment if you're taking
virtue ethics near using play-doh you're
not back in ancient Greece right you're
in 21st century America and you have to
somehow make what you studied relevant
to something that could have
for century America well Thomas Aquinas
did they in the 13th century the High
Middle Ages he has one of the things
that was going on that is they in the
West we've lost a lot of rest Italian
taxes they gathered in the east and the
Arabs had translated them and preserve
them and they came through Spain or
ginger to Western Europe and all these
you know people teaching like Thomas
Aquinas yeah these great university
towns suddenly had all this material
that was you know there to make sense of
things Aristotle is a great philosopher
hopefully through reading and at least
make me go through thinking about some
of the things he's open your mind to
some things you hadn't thought of before
or you've thought about things in ways
you haven't looked at it before like say
your friendships right or whether you're
responsible for your own actions in this
way or that way or where you want to go
with your life may be thinking about
happiness reoriented something for you
well that same thing happened with these
guys and there was kind of a conflict
like so this is actually going to lead
us into talking about two different
theories we have even talked about so
far and raising an issue that we haven't
thought about so far remember at the
beginning of the semester I had to do
that list and I saw okay what do you
guys
what do you care about and you know
first thing you guys that was family
right and they have sort of coax out to
you that some of you would actually like
to have some money which usually isn't a
problem with the students usually had
some of the first things they say but
you guys are actually you know you have
fairly good moral compasses so you you
know you named off things like having a
good career friends eventually you know
you said you have pleasures just with
the same pleasures and then it's
somebody in here I don't remember the
ones that got you guys remember that
point there's a long time ago and if you
bring up stuff like that and we're
talking about moral issues especially in
our culture people can get very
uncomfortable not supposed to talk about
the classroom well that's that's
actually kind of a strange viewpoint
because throughout history most of the
people that were studying had some sort
of views on god Aristotle had views on
god the Greeks believed in God's
Aristotle actually didn't believe them
than the same gods of the Greeks did he
believed in something much more similar
to what Thomas was talking about Plato
talks about the gods Epictetus talks
about the gods the people that we're
going to read later on in the semester
some of them were atheists some of them
are agnostic some of the more committed
Christians well fit committed Christians
of some sort of you know sort at least
Thomas Hobbes was aggression but he has
reviews when he was in the way to call
church at one Thomas Aquinas is right in
the center of all these sort of
controversies and one of the big issues
that you have to think about when it
comes to talking about religion and
ethics is can they be brought together
or if you bring up religion are you
automatically sort of closing the door
to anybody who doesn't share your
beliefs even if your name is that could
be an issue if you are hardcore
committed atheist and you have a epics
that has no room for God maybe other
people can't share your views so there's
two types of moral theory that we're
going to talk about and grapple with
these issues let's lay out what if it's
the conference so it's framed like this
in the Middle Ages Aristotle at the
church and if you know anything about
Galileo on the Galileo controversy by
the time that that takes place Aristotle
is somebody who's actually getting very
accepted in the church and you know
Galileo am I against aristotelianism
there's a lot more to that story because
Galileo was kind of a jerk and trekking
to force people's hands and stuff like
that and not everybody in the church was
for was for century al Alejo
blaze across small really bad idea but
by the attend Marisol Dakota why well
when Arizona first came out but that
first marathon first arrived in the
Latin West he was felt to be presenting
a real challenge to church doctrine you
know Aristotle taught things like when
the body dies the soul does not survive
or the world has been here from eternity
if you know much about you know Jewish
tradition it was in theology we realized
those are big problems right if you want
to make that person here central thinker
you got a problem because all those
religions teach that the soul survives
after the death of the body and they all
teach that the world began as certain
type so you've got a couple different
options there right think about it this
way you've got two friends your friends
don't get along what can you do and yes
up early yeah you can you can do what we
call compartmentalization so you can say
well you know when it jumps to physics
will look will read Aristotle when it
comes to things about you know FX well
we'll use the church doctrine so you
could you can compartmentalize that's
often not very satisfying
your friend sees you another place catch
on leading this kind of double life I am
I'll tell you this very sick story but
very imprudent friend of mine log debt
unfortunately my best friend and he was
a nice guy really loyal but one of his
character flaws was he always had to
have two or three girlfriends and you
know that could be workable if they do
about each other and they were okay with
it that sort of thing but do you think
that's what he did what he would do is
he would first start dating 10 and
things would be going great with her oh
I think she's the one and all that and
then inexplicably he had another girl
that he'd need over here and she's a lot
of fun to can start going out with both
of them and he tried to keep them
completely separate from each other so
now he's living two different love lives
and then you get a third one and what do
you have to do in cases like that in
order to keep it going you have to tell
lies right yeah the problem with this
guy if you're really really smart I
guess you could probably get away with
telling lies but unless you can keep
track of all those lives sooner or later
people are going to start seeing through
them and these girls would always start
seeing through it so the whole house of
cards and come tumbling down and the
first couple times we were like you know
you know we're good friends
you're trying like all this is bad you
know dr. see the error of your ways
shouldn't do this sort of thing and then
after a while we realized this is just
the way he was and he was going to keep
doing this and we will just watch
entertain now can you do that with faith
and reason you know if you have a
religious faith that's really core to
your to your identity to how you think
about things it's not just going to
church on Sunday and then doing whatever
the hell you want to do press the week
so it's actually part of who you are
part of the way you approach things
that's pretty deeply rooted reason under
that's also very deeply rooted that's
part of your very nature as a human
being that's what separates you from the
animals so if you're going to separate a
faith and reason I like two friends who
can't get can't get along you're
probably going to be living two
different lives but they will catch you
did you ever you met mr. burr holes okay
so what else can you do with two friends
we can't get along yeah if you know you
can just hang out with the other and if
they're going to be immature about it
you should drop the funnest your foot
you can take sides you can kick one out
in favor of the other yeah that's a
possibility one for one second and
that's what some people did in the
Middle Ages they would side purely for
reason or purely for faith yeah mediate
between them you can try to reconcile
them in some way to get them to see that
the other person may have something
valid on their side that's what's
promised opted for so the question is
whether it's going to be faithful first
reason they just compartmentalized or
maybe you side with one against the
other or you somehow try to reconcile
them and it's not always easy
there are some things about the nature
of human reason and review of faith that
make that synthesis difficult but not
necessarily impossible something like
Thomas is a good example some people
would actually thought you can't
reconcile them so there are people like
Paul rationalists nowadays we often poem
secularists and they believe that look
faith is totally irrational and you know
if we're going to have an ethics or
we're going to have any sort of coherent
philosophy it's got to be purely
rational you have to get rid of anything
religious that any religious commitments
are going to be an impediment to
thinking things through right that's one
viewpoint you take that's not a
viewpoint Thomas takes that's what we
call rationalism or again in
contemporary terms we call seculars
another way you can go is is you side
with faith in you say reason is no good
and this has been around for a long time
there are a lot of famous people have
taken this position Martin Luther for
example really interesting often I like
reading Luther and parka consists of
such wild things he says reason is a
[ __ ] well you know he wouldn't really
trust a prostitute to give you true
testimony widget that sort of Luther
would would commonly say he was very
earthy say about that
sort of language I don't I won't say
some of the other stuff he said because
you know it's actually going on video
and do stuff but he what was he why was
he doing that well he thought that faith
was so important that if you mix in
purely human reason you're gonna you're
going to screw it up Peter dania during
the Middle Ages not that far removed
from Thompson point it's great example
of somebody who said faith is it and
even studying grammar is bad not
studying philosophy just studying
grammar grammar is the tool of the devil
and we have people like this today right
oftentimes we call the fundamentalist so
that's an in exact term the actual
fundamentalists are actually pretty
small group we use the term very loosely
another term you can use is feed a asst
those who you know privilege faith over
reason the Thomas doesn't go that way
either Thomas is trying to bring about a
synthesis of the two and he thinks that
faith and reason if they're actually
being understood right if they're
actually being used right so not just
the faith of something somebody who's a
hypocrite say but genuine faith and not
just the reason if somebody who uses
reason and kind of self-serving layered
as we follow things out but the reason
when the person really you know thinks
things through they're ultimately going
to come to the same conclusions so what
that means is that for merely any thing
that the faith is teaching if you look
hard enough you could
some rational justification so for
instance we're not going to talk about
this in this class we talked about the
central philosophy if you're if you're a
Christian or Jew or Muslim do believe
God exists or not yes you can't you
can't be a Jew or a Christian or Muslim
and say well I don't know there's god I
don't believe there is a God then you'd
be something different right whether God
exists or not is this something you can
solve I just looking outside can you do
a litmus test for it it's got a leader
out there is can't do that you have to
do it by argument and the thing you know
whether it's drew Judaism or
Christianity or Islam what are they you
know great monotheistic religions his
teaching that God exists it's not
necessarily providing an argument the
way jack philosophy would do and so in
your intro to philosophy class you
probably looked at some arguments for
God's existence right yeah that's
logical argument logical argument the
teleological argument I don't know how
they thought it here that's usually how
you go through it that would be a case
where something that finger learned
originally from faith they tried to
reason out with philosophy you can do
the same thing in ethics let's take a
ten commandments what are the Ten
Commandments tell you that you shouldn't
do should you commit adultery it's
against that right yeah it doesn't you
know does that mean that if you're not
married and do anything you want is that
the way the Ten Commandments actually
work I'm not covered into that case
because I'm not married I'm divorced now
I actually saw you know does that mean
I'm free myself to do whatever I want
yes I'm following no it's understood a
little bit more Rob
you're not supposed to be having sexual
relations outside of defined sphere of
marriage as usually understood so you
can get that principle from faith right
do you have to be a philosopher to to
know that you shouldn't cheat on your
spouse I hope time how many of your
majoring in philosophy not in here
because if I know asked before so that
means you hear your gut cheat on your
spouse right because you know the
philosophy major I think full-time know
you could you can only you're not
supposed to do that because maybe you
know and you see all these signs that
people put in their yards of the Ten
Commandments thou shalt not commit
adultery I say that applies to me as
well as other people right but you could
also reason let's say you didn't have
that that you didn't have the Ten
Commandments not everybody did could you
reach the the notion that you shouldn't
she done your spouse by picking it out
you could that's one of the great things
about human beings we don't just have to
be told an authoritative way howdy we
can actually reason it out for ourselves
is there anything that would maybe lead
you astray so that you would reach that
conclusion sure remember we talked about
this with Aristotle your your emotions
your passions can lead you astray and
said well that that's polish next door
it looks really good i know i shouldn't
but me I should too so your reasoning
doesn't always go right but if your
reasoning is going right you should be
able to figure out the way that you
ought to behave right before you say as
I say
if you're an eagles then you really
might not care what your wife face or
the rest I was like so you probably go
try that yeah and you notice the
different moral theories that we've
studied so let's take Eagle is the
missing example actually let's use
egoism and contract arianism this two
examples they both articulate ways in
which we reason about things and the
egoist is self setting and everything is
judged in accordance with their
interests or their desires so if you
know [ __ ] is going to say wha not
going to cheat on my spouse why would we
do man it's a lot of pleasure to cheat
on your spouse that's what people do it
if there are really two main reasons
there's all the reasons to there's two
main reasons people cheat on their
spouses what would they be probably get
inside of them yeah and so you want to
get pleasure people do the entire with
each other in relationships you're not
really married there's FF Kathleen right
so there's there's the lower pleasure
and what's the one other big reason why
people cheat on their spouses sometimes
exactly anger show them you know and
these could be connected like maybe your
spouse isn't paying enough attention to
you because they're you know tired you
wanted to show that you know um an
egoist those are desires those articles
are caches and he goes might say well I
you know my spouse no longer satisfies
me the way that they did
first married I would like to be
satisfied this person next door looks
awfully good I should go sleep with them
and what would hold it goes back well
there may be a reasoning like this if I
cheat with this person next door their
spouse is going to get angry and shoot a
I want to get shot at therefore I won't
cheat with that but then that just tells
you to find somebody else that you it
doesn't tell you cheating is wrong right
doesn't tell you you shouldn't sheep at
all a contract you're going to look at a
little bit differently remember contract
areas are about agreements and keeping
social order and what would happen let's
pretend we're all married people now
right and each one of you has a spouse
what would happen if one of us starts
cheating you know as somebody else's
spouse that's kind of breaking the
social contract because the social
contract and say I keep my hands off
your stuff right
yeah the ego is can't find reasons not
to do things that most people consider
bad like say cheating on spouses but the
ego is reasoning for that will just be
because that would negatively affect me
and that could be a good reason I
shouldn't cheat on my spouse because I
don't want them to get out of revenge
cheat on me because that would go
against my desires so yeah the egos
can't arrive at those conclusions notice
the difference the ego is never says
this is just the wrong thing to do
that's not available from that
perspective the contract carrier cancer
that's the wrong thing to do because it
violates the social contract somebody
like Thomas Aquinas could say for a
couple reasons it's wrong because God
says not to do it Oh God doesn't like
you're cheating on your spouse's could
be wrong because it goes against
something having to do with reason you
know I'm going to talk more about that
later on this is leading edge towards
these two different types of ethics
there's one called the divine command
theory Thomas is not an example of the
divine command theory the divine command
theory of morality says God says do this
therefore this is the right thing to do
God says don't do this therefore this is
the wrong thing and there's a lot of
people who run their lives and make
their moral decisions based on that sort
of idea right if that's if that's the
case the key thing is to figure out what
God actually wants that it could be it
could be God or it could be the gods it
could be anything you left it could be
you know with the great potato chip in
the skies what matters is that there's
some sort of Supreme Being some greater
being and that being tells you what to
do and what's right or wrong is what was
it according to death yeah
I feel like oh wait they do the church
if it is straightforward I think when
you try to rationalize yourself agrees
yeah
yes yeah you know that's a good point
now somebody like Thomas would say that
you could step back and look at your
reasoning process and you can
distinguish wrongly using reason just to
rationalize satisfying your desires
which is what you're talking about right
where your desire leads and then reason
is that I actually telling you what to
do reason is just being used as a tool
to satisfy what they want and then write
you some reason where you're using
amazin to regulate you know last week
you catch yourself actually
rationalizing one of the things you can
do is you can say what I do it you know
I'm uh I've come to the conclusion that
it's okay we'll use the cheating again
it's okay to cheat on my spouse there
must be something wrong with this and
then you can start looking at yourself
and say hi I've got a strong desire to
cheat on my spouse or just just have sex
in general right because we have strong
desires that okay I shouldn't be using
reason this way you you can step back
and actually do that so not every case
using reason is just egoistic
rationalizing we can use your easily
figure out what we ought to do but when
you're since we've started off with
samples that the church or some other
moral authority can provide harbingers
guidelines and that maybe it's better to
rely on those
lie on reason because reason can lead us
astray one of the interesting things
that Thomas points out and you see this
in a lot of churches is this notion that
what is our nature what did God make us
why ears are getting into you know
theology anthropology person he made us
rational beings so using reason would be
something that God would actually want
from us and not everybody teaches this
there's some churches that each turn
reason off just a non reason but at
least the church that Thomas is working
yet at least some time as long as
practitioners thinks that reason is a
good thing and you want to try to prune
a way that they add parts because human
reason is damaged but it's not
completely unreliable so two questions
well I have a flaw quite according to
this view point putting the church's
view point everybody's fly so her one
one guy you know everything
I mean that that's that's one of the
things you need in order to get religion
off the ground so that's sort of yeah
it'd be sort of like saying to a soccer
club you have to prove that that soccer
scrutiny at your club it'd be a little
bit part before the horse I mean there's
all sorts of criticisms you could make
an organized religion that's probably
not the one that's going to hold much
water well then we're going to move up
because we've limited class I'm not
drinking us up together like a big
debate about value organized religion
I'm giving you a context for what Thomas
is doing so divine command theory what
is this going to say like having faith
without reasons kind of like this on
somebody oh you didn't do this let me
say already shut to your child yeah oh
you shouldn't go up as not they're going
to say oh well why not yes and then
they're going to just sit up without
reasonable if they don't use their
reasoning skills they get all when you
want them to follow they may not follow
what you want because they don't have
the reasoning like okay why am I doing
this or if you want something to do
something and they don't understand why
they know yet they might not be able to
do it that specific one yeah i mean with
again i don't want to get too far games
with kids you can't reason with about
having point that's why we have extra
resort to the shop and do it but you're
right with different what adults who can
actually use reason they have to have
some practice in relying on
just like we do baying some authority
because you know I mean these are habits
if your habit is to blindly obey some
authority and never think about whether
the authorities the right authority it's
very hard to break that habit oftentimes
you know people do when they leave a
religious group that lies on wine
authority they find some other thing
that's just sasura tative I think they
leave a church hardcore atheist and
they're almost like a fundamentalist of
a you know or they go the other way now
what I want to get to so we have the
divine command here things are right
just because God says they're right
things are wrong because God says their
minds only God's sort of Fiat or will
that makes itself so with the divine
command theory one of the problems with
this what if God tomorrow said thou
shalt commit adultery that it would be
good there are some some religious
groups that hold that polygamy is a
sacred duty they claim that that God is
telling them that this is the case they
rely have a divine command theory it
becomes very difficult if your divine
command theory and your understanding of
what God is saying says we shouldn't
commit adultery but there is says well
actually we got this book and it says in
here that God told us we should have
multiple wives most days and usually
when you find this it's not why shaving
multiple husbands it's almost always
husband's having multiple wives but
shouldn't they get to be a little bit no
suspicious what's kind of that with some
of these right but how can you reconcile
those you know it seems like the divine
command theory one of the problems with
it is there's an awful lot of religious
groups aren't there and they don't all
teach the same
a point do that well one of the other
possibilities for ax that he has some
sort of religious connection is what we
call natural law theory this is what
Thomas actually proposes which is that
you know some things by faith and then
you try to see whether you can use
reason to actually get to those same
points and if it turns out that you can
you know why that's the case because God
is placed within human beings a natural
law so if you didn't know that it's not
okay to kill its criminals you know to
go around mow down human beings you
could actually think that through and
figure that out on your own I hope so
alright if you didn't have the Ten
Commandments I mean they're you know Ten
Commandments it around I'll shalt not
murder is in there everyone's going to
killing each other no because we have
certain inclinations Thomas says and if
we think those out we realize that
reason tells us there's a certain light
way to live now where did that reason
come from well you know ultimately from
if we're created beings ultimately from
God but you have to have God like in
there in the picture actively saying now
she'll call shell in order to get this
off the ground you don't so is this
something that maybe you let's say
you're a believer in one of the great
three miles accusing
let's say your best friend is an atheist
could you guys both reason together not
whether you should steal their usual I
whether you should kill you could good
maybe what you'd be doing them pretty me
Thomas is discovering the natural law
that you believe in God an atheist just
that well that's just the way we happen
to think and you don't actually need the
Atheist to say God place that wall there
or anything like that so long as they
can recognize it live by it they're not
going to kill you we're still trivia or
cheap you know your stocks rely that
would be pretty good good enough so
natural law theory has a religious basis
but it's not a religious epic in the
same way that the divine command theory
is divine command theory if you don't
belong to somebody else's religious
group you're not going to find very
convincing there are statements about
what God has told them they have to do
you have to do how many of you faster
and Rhonda going too fast out of out of
some solidarity with their Muslim
brother I'm going to view
most Christian culture so most anger
probably how many of you celebrate any
holidays no why not well because you
don't believe that those are divinely
commanded right if you actually did
believe that you had faster and one
whole month of the year the wedge
Muslims do because God told you then he
would be believing in the divine command
theory wouldn't you the divine command
theory has interpreted by this group
perhaps you actually you know can
recognize some of what you do is if
you're a religious believer has like a
divine command theory or like the
natural law theory we're going to
explore the natural law theory we would
explore the divine command theory but we
don't have enough time in the semester
so all of that step let's look at the
actual reading and question Thomas
Aquinas is approaching the question who
else raise this in central question s
Plato tip that somebody that way to be
studying just recently aerosol and this
is why Thomas's reasons he thinks that
just like memory ourselves at well you
got to get the big picture before you
can go to work out details you got to
figure out what you're really striving
mr. what it looks like you know for your
whole life not just focus on individual
actions Thomas is doing the same thing
and he wants to know what is the
greatest
satisfying good and you know people have
different views on the stone s the crack
addict with the most satisfying good is
what do they pick it is crap decade mike
says Washington Dave Chappelle's from
last night yesterday i'm glad he's back
on the air like has come he asked
somebody who each other spouse all the
time and that seems to be the main
center of their life what's you know
what's the good life having sex with as
many people as possible physical
pleasure right physical pleasure of a
different story ask somebody to
sacrifices for their kids and works to
three jobs what's the most important
thing in life they may say their kids
right what will make them happy seeing
their kids prosper thomas considers
eight different sets of questions could
they have pretty happiness to this
Goodie happiness be that's pretty
happiness bruins you know she doesn't
20s format i'll talk more about his
format next next class he doesn't come
right out and say here's what I think he
considers other people's points of view
this is an important thing if you want
to actually have your own point of view
be good you have to actually show you
can consider everybody else's point of
view how many of you are business majors
again so when you go in and you give a
report you're going to have somebody
else giving a report alongside you and
you've got to be able to say why you
report is better and you can't do them
as you understand their report if you're
proposing a solution to the problem to
your company
your boss wants the doll that you can
actually tell them why this is for her
why this is a better option that's what
Thomas is about here so what does he
start it starts with one of the same
thing we saw these were well what's
wrong well how many of you don't want
money I mean some people actually live
lives of poppy really some hippie types
you're not going posing something like
that interposing looking not with modest
means right what me to survive but what
to wrap themselves too much oh my god
yeah what and Thomas introduces an
interesting distinction here he talks
about the actual and artificial bone
natural wealth is like you know your
clothes food drink the things that
satisfy your basic needs shelter
transportation notice he includes
transportation there along with all
these other thoughts he's not part of a
cemetery society the Middle Ages were
not as dark
what is artificial one or things that
compromise so your bank accounts what's
good about your bank account so you can
spend that to get this stuff can you buy
you know this proverbial song those can
money buy you love they can buy you
people hanging out with you and saying
they love you maybe the gifts if you
really buy the right gifts you can you
know get the person to start loving you
thoughtful gifts not just expensive
gifts what else can't my little lot of
things money can't action by what about
good to the bond I mean I have to go to
the doctor pretty soon for my first you
know whatever you call it physical with
a GP a family doctor
I'm going to these going to want money
isn't he and if she says you need to
take this this drug of that drug if I go
to the pharmacy I said well the doctor
says I need to have this draw can i have
it please really gonna say pink for so
there are some goods of the body can
spending money get me in shape well yes
and no ok how can spend money get me in
shape you can you can hire a trainer you
can just like now listen to your trainer
and set up a cow just spend the money by
itself is not gonna get in shape you
actually you have to exercise don't you
the particles people can leave by gym
memberships for six months when he came
to do that that's a good of the body so
a money like you put it out got money is
not the thing that's been a beanie
acting us being bridge is not
necessarily being happy as a matter of
fact that didn't happiness studies and
they find out that at least in the
Western countries rich people aren't
really that happy they're marginally
happier than porting it is it is better
you know as far as happiness goes to
have more wealth than they have last but
it's not enough so what are the next
contestant he talks about other external
goods any types of Fame glory
and I noticed you talked about all these
is being external goods now money okay
it's easy to see what that's external
right for a property I can take this
sweater off to another splinter huh I
could you know swaps waters is not
sweaters we do the sweater sweatshirt
with mr. prime right we can exchange her
are probably put the ones i I'm just a
little bit different honors is
pertaining to the person we talked about
this before and notice Thomas's
distinguishing honor and fame or glory
reputation and all of you want to be
honored to some degree you want people
to respect you why do people respect you
though do they automatically they just
do that look people respect you for
accomplishments that's one thing we're
inside I'll just see your actions ah
yeah so the accomplishments are what
happened from your actions your reaction
what are your reactions display about
you yeah so we're honored for good
things about us that means of Honor
itself can't be the final good because
if it's for the sake of something else
if it is derived from something else
maybe categories will be the final good
maybe that's that's for happiness well
but it can't be honored did you just
going to say like the way you carry and
stuff yeah although that's good I think
have more to do with glory okay this is
more like just reputation people looking
at me and saying that person's important
that person's good why isn't that good
well let's see what Thomas actually says
in that case he says this glory consists
in being well-known and praised the
thing no one is related to human
knowledge otherwise that the gods
knowledge human knowledge knowledge of
somebody else's States is kind of in a
perfect distance do you really know like
in their heart of hearts people that you
deal with whether they're say they have
good character now you know some general
signs but you can be mistaken caption
and you can always ask you know what are
we why do we make people things roommate
people things for our society for the
big famous people entertainers right so
comedians musicians actors my leaving
anything out and yeah I guess you could
call a updates in a certain
entertainers although they be almost
more would be like dancers were
extremely demanding physically so those
are some people that we make it to
celebrities right who else are
celebrities some politicians become
celebrities right some people actually
like get into politics and then it turns
out that it's actually more lucrative
for them to not be in charge and not
have power and just to have fame like
mike huckabee grant for president it's
kind of loan TV shut down you're not
running for president anymore he's got a
very successful TV show where he talks
about he's very the trouble of having to
do it well all of these things are
valuing somebody for something else we
have some celebrities who became
celebrities just by like you know having
a lot of Facebook friends like tila
tequila that's how she made her bones
she had a huge amount of friends I they
may not have been on facebook in vitamin
in my space we have other people who are
famous for being famous in Paris Hilton
well that's pretty ng is that's not
actually happiness that's an external
good what about power having power over
people now we're kind of tired their
game to make people do what you want I
mean if you have power you can handle
all these other things can't you this is
this burden why the Occupy Wall Street
movement and the Tea Party movement have
so many adherents and are so angry
they're actually angry a lot of the same
things having to do with other people
who we have power and use that power to
get all this stuff that everybody else
expense would be part of the ninety-nine
percent and fifty-three percent or you
know whenever you want to say you're not
going to powerful are you wouldn't it be
nice to have the power be able to tell
people what to do think about how easy a
life would be if you were king for a day
Binford a working for life yeah those
guys that just because you have power
doesn't mean even be happy because if
you get use your power to get three
negative results they didn't want like
let's say you know we have movies like
that goin nowhere somebody gets power
and what do they do they screw things up
like Bruce Almighty that's that's a
whole that's the whole premise of that
movie through salt lighting another
movie s or like that is click because
everything that we were he's got the
remote and he can fast-forward any fast
force through most of his life you must
get through boring conversations with
his life and ends up being stranger
power is not by itself good or bad they
can use for good ends or can be used for
bad so that means it can't be that good
it can't be happiness so these are all
external is what's more yours what
belongs to you if we strip away your
wealth is strip away reputation
wait Paula when you still have enough to
work how you feel yeah that's actually
your sort of skipping ahead to what
caused the soul what else do you have
the action also part of your soul
getting in it's what's sitting in you
know in the chair no those are you ready
athletes this is what you work out
you're not working out your soul work
out your your body right and there's a
bit of the body right what are some of
the things that make a body good being
alive as opposed to being dead that's a
big one preservation of life but that's
not the only thing what else is good
about body or couldn't do it one locks
right being being tractive if you look
at the mirror and you're happy with what
you see them here that's a component of
happiness isn't it if you look at the
mirror and you think that you look good
you're probably going to be less yeah p
or onion sure there are some people who
even if they they know there's all sorts
of disorders you know we call body
dysmorphic oh you guys familiar with the
sternal body dysmorphic like someone
thinks
it could be could be facial features
very often it has to do with the whole
frame length women tend to get it in
terms of fatness and fitness so women
who are you know constantly losing
weight because their handler xik look in
the mirror and they actually see
somebody was bad they're seeing a
hallucination lesser men tend to get it
in terms of bulking up so there are
these guys were gigantic and they look
in the mirror and they don't actually
see a guy who's almost totally Hulk like
muscle-bound they see a guy who's got
thin arms so you know appearance is a
good of the body we do spend a lot of
attention up not just society smell
touch people's skin should be smooth you
know it's fully it or whatever I just
getting stuff so what else is good for
the body but buddy health the aerosol
says when somebody's sick I'm going
through this right now myself happiness
consists in not being sick and getting
better you know you almost forget what
it's like to not be sick now could the
goods of the body be truly satisfied he
also sought but right and pleasure you
have pleasures of difference you have
all sorts of bodily pleasures you know
you like eating right if you like some
food that's bottle that's your senses
you like listening to music right how do
you how do you take it music through
your ears any of you
like scented candles where coloma
perfume or things like that you just put
on any old Cologne reach for the first
thing you can see in the store no your
life certain things don't you that they
did bring you pleasure could go to the
body bialy happens well let's see you
again what Thomas actually says why why
not well there's two problems one is are
you just your bottom if you're a
materialist then you probably think yes
if you believe that you have soul then
how could a good of the body the the
be-all and end-all when you've also got
this thing called soul think about
people who work out all the time and
they don't appear to be particularly
happy that's resolved there in prime
physical health but they're not hand
because they should neglect of the soul
where they have plastic surgery all the
time look really great
I'm going to pleasure this is one we've
had before all of your pledge pleasure
none of you are a hedonic meaning you
don't enjoy a pleasant Pleasant things
that would be terrible because pleasure
does feel really good different kinds of
why can't pleasure to the good well
Thomas tossing life and this is where it
gets really interesting this he has to
do with his understanding of human
nature he says first two things we
experienced a lot of different kinds of
pleasure or provided and which the most
people know the best they now pleasure
to the soul or intellect war or they
know pleasure to the bottom in our
society hi yeah we can all relate to
that there anybody or doesn't like
eating food you know there's no food
that you like you crave sometimes
anybody here it doesn't like listen to
music anybody here who doesn't enjoy I'm
going out on a nice day being outside
yeah Todd okay
I'm sure I'm not asking about very
specific cases I'm just asking in
general you enjoy enjoy the reason I be
asking this is to make a [ __ ] about
physical delights we can all relate to
these are their pleasures that are not
bottling how many of you have enjoyed
reading a book that was not bodily
pleasure according to todd miss Rivera
Solomon like that that's something that
you enjoy because you have a soul you
have an intellect you have a mind how
many of you have enjoyed just being with
with a friend or a family member yeah
that's not just a pleasure at the bottom
that's a pleasure this is a wide the
soul or the mind that's a high reward
we're going to talk more office when we
get the John Stuart Mill later in the
semester so what he says okay so a lot
of things are pleasures the body and
then it talks about this stuff about
essences improper accidents and that's a
lot of metaphysics that's going to be
hard to understand so I'm going to skip
over that but what he says is every
delight is something that results from
happiness or from some part of happiness
the reason a man is delighted is get
some fitting good some good that's
appropriate to him so mr. mr. Schwartz
what's your favorite food any cow
chicken really wow you're easy to please
mrs. fryer what's your account
what's up King crowned king well that's
going to get ya okay what's mamas is
calling the fitting good is going to
vary from person to person depending on
say their their tapes so from this prior
king crab is at the top of the the rank
for mr. Schwartz it's something
different it's some other kind of need
like me but might be chocolate for
somebody else in here is there anybody
in here with chocolates their favorite
thing that would be another fitting good
there are all sorts of goods that are
appropriate to to us and notice there
you can say they are generic they're
both kinds of food they won't have
favorite foods right but they're they're
different so when you have your fitting
good that makes you happy so you know
like it says it's when you either have
it in reality or hope or memory so think
about the last time you had king crab
yeah and now think about that that taste
and that that that memory and you
actually start to feel a little bit
better there's actually a sort of trick
you can pull on yourself if you're not
feeling good think about any happy
thoughts why does that actually work for
us because we experience that delight
not if I tell you know this isn't true
but let's say I were to say if you get
an A in this class I'm going to buy you
king crab now you're hoping for king
crab right but I'm not by giving a king
crab
and about an adjunct salary so even less
than what I made as a professor but
that's an appropriate good thinking
about thinking about the enjoyment of
you feel pleasure and some life it's
those goods that gave you the pleasure
with the pleasure itself is not
happiness those goods are productive so
that can't be what about goods in the
soul themselves like states of character
this is where you know Aristotle would
have said yeah that's it Thomas is going
beyond and Thomas says the soul is not
the end human beings were ordered to
something higher than just the human
soul for Aristotle you know perfecting
the human soul bringing out the virtues
that was it that was the best thing you
can have doing that with friends
actually got to put it remember virtuous
activity with sufficient means and with
friends to share it with that was it for
Harrison Thomas is looking beyond of
course because he's he's being this
Christian tradition and so are Jewish
aristotelianism puzzle knows it's
killing us and he's saying if we think
about human beings last and soul is not
that you enjoy happiness through your
soul but just perfecting your soul is
not the be-all
so what could be at the very end yes can
any created hood be happy we've actually
run through all the different categories
of 380 goods what do we mean by created
because good is an art gala there's only
there would only do one thing that's not
created in this framework right and I'm
not saying you in finals I won't make
that very clear we're doing here is
trying to understand Thomas's position
not trying to endorse Thomas's position
but if you bind with this framework then
there's creative goods everything that
we see here everything that we
experience and then there's a 100 good
what is that that's God what are what do
our wills what do our deepest desires
actually Thomas is going to say the only
object that could be truly satisfied
that isn't just part of happiness
there's happiness itself is god that's
kind of a weird thing to say we need
even for a body religious believers lot
of religious believers want to get in
good with God because God will do it my
stuff or God will make them handy right
is God itself himself tree self Jim
Therrien Christian I guess happiness
itself that's where i'ma leave because
it's kind of a Miss applause you have to
think about a bit for it to make some
sense this is where Thomas's go he
thinks that our last act our ultimate
goal
relationship with God and that all these
other things are sort of that simply as
long